part the movie is set in 200 BCE ancient
Greece whereas Spartan Elder observes a
newborn baby which looks like Shrek the
narrator explains that if any
imperfections are found then the baby is
rejected as the first baby is green and
ugly it is thrown into the pile down
below which consists of corpses and
Bones baby Shrek not dead baby Shrek
could get revenge soon the second baby
turns out to be of Vietnamese descent
and the narrator explains that he will
be adopted by Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie
narratorception the third and final baby
is accepted as a Spartan for his already
present beard and his muscular physique
he is then named Leonidas from a young
age Leonidas is brutally trained for
Knighthood and spars with his
grandmother as he grows up Leonidas is
also tortured and taught to show no pain
one day he is cast out into the wild to
survive the harsh winter conditions on
his own with barely any clothes there a
beast with red eyes stalks him and it's
revealed to be a giant penguin without
wasting any time the penguin proceeds to
abuse Leonidas by jumping on him and
body slamming him to the ground however
our brave protagonist manages to
outsmart the penguin by trapping it into
a tight spot he then finds a penguin
spear inside a random glass box and
kills the Beast with it after the winter
passes through Leonidas returns back to
Sparta for his inauguration as king
while wearing a penguin skin hat
realizing that he has slain the deadly
Beast all the people bow in his presence
however Leonidas appears to be
infatuated with a beautiful girl in the
crowd named Margot she dances erotically
while sucking on a lollipop and winking
constantly this is enough to win
Leonidas over so without thinking twice
he asks her to marry him to his Delight
Margot responds by giving him the
combination to her armor-plated chastity
belt the movie then cuts to several
years later where it is revealed that
Leonidas has become the King of Sparta
currently he is violently training his
son while Margot watches from the
sidelines Leonidas aggressively throws
his son around and headbutts him
teaching him that he must learn to take
powerful hits from his enemies boy
Margot suggests that he do the pile
driver on his son and so Leonidas drives
his son's head into the floor whoops I
think Margot meant she wanted Leonidas
to pile drive her not the kid shortly
after leonidas's best friend named the
captain arrives there and reveals that
the messenger of Persia has come to talk
with him so Leonidas ends his training
with his son and heads to meet the
messenger he then greets his guest with
a French kiss claiming that in Sparta
they shake hands with women and kiss the
man the two of them then hold hands and
take a walk as they continue chatting
the messenger of Persia tells Leonidas
that the great Persian King Xerxes has
taken over the world with his vast Army
now he wants to conquer Sparta as his
last Conquest hearing this Leonidas
becomes infuriated so he takes the
messenger and his accomplices over to
the pit of death but even there the
Persians warned the Spartans to
surrender immediately if they want to
prevent the a war in addition the
messenger explains the Persian King
Xerxes demands that the Spartans must
build his pyramids the women will be
used as escorts and the children will
work in factories to produce shoes while
a Spartan politician named tretoro is in
favor of surrendering Leonidas strictly
refuses he then kicks the messenger down
the pit of death along with his
accomplices officially starting the war
with the Persians following the incident
many celebrities including Britney
Spears Kevin Federline Sanjaya malakar
Ryan Seacrest appear before the pit of
death and Leonidas kicks all of them
down furthermore all the judges of
American Idol including Simon Cowell
pre-ridiculous facelift Randy Jackson
and Paula Abdul also suddenly appear
they insult the Spartan King by telling
him that his kicks were very poor okay I
can't believe that these movies aired in
theaters Leonidas is furious and as a
result he shoves them down the pit as
well afterwards the captain suggests
that before confronting the Persians
Leonidas should consult with the prophet
turns out that the prophets are advisers
to the King of Sparta so the same
evening Leonidas visits them with a
bunch of cosmetic products as their
consultation fee however the prophets
advise him to consult with the Oracle
instead the Oracle is supposed to be the
chosen from the most beautiful of women
but she is actually the famous Ugly
Betty the Oracle of Sparta that informs
Leonidas that he will die should he go
to war against Persia and Xerxes despite
the clear warning Leonidas decides to go
to war anyway at night he cannot sleep
due to the immense pressure on his
shoulders and seeing this Margot
mentions that he can do whatever he
likes with her even give her the pile
Drive Leonidas likes the idea but
instead of pleasing her he starts using
her as a weight to exercise
the following day Leona just happily
heads out to meet his army assembled by
the captain however his expression
quickly changes when he learns that a
mere 13 soldiers fit into his stringent
requirements among them the captain's
only son sonio is also present the odds
are firmly stacked against the Spartans
but despite this Leonidas wants to
proceed with the plan so after saying
goodbye to his family he along with the
captain and the Warriors set out for
their venture to Thermopylae meanwhile
the Spartan politician tretoro is
revealed to be a traitor as he informs
Xerxes everything via email upon
reaching the hot Gates of Thermopylae
the Spartans take a moment to replenish
their thirst by consuming their favorite
drink Gatorade suddenly Leonidas and the
captain encounter a deformed Paris
Hilton who reveals a secret goat path
above the hot Gates apparently Xerxes is
planning to outflank the Spartans using
it she then asks to be made a Spartan
warrior but Leonidas quickly rejects her
after seeing her hold a spear the
incorrect direct away afterwards
Leonidas and his 13-man army face off
with the Persian army leader and his
troops out of nowhere one of the
Spartans named dillios lunges towards
the Persians to attack but miserably
fails as he jumps over them and crashes
into a nearby Hill with this the two
parties fight an intense battle but not
in the way one would imagine they
actually indulge in a game of dance-off
which the Spartans eventually win with
their flashy moves as a punishment for
losing they drive the Persians off of a
cliff and into the sea with this Our
Heroes succeed in defending Thermopylae
from the first wave of attackers in the
meantime in Sparta the local loyalist
visits Margot who is in the middle of a
massage he talks to her about how
Leonidas stands no chance against the
Persians with only 13 men so he wants
Margot to convince the council to
assemble more troops the only obstacle
that they must face is the Spartan
politician Trey Toro as he is also one
of the council members but fortunately
Margot manages to seduce him using her
assets back in Thermopylae the Persian
King Xerxes visits Leonidas himself and
tries to convince him to surrender
Sparta the two then play a game of Deal
or No Deal where Xerxes tries to bribe
him with a trip to the Palms Hotel and
Casino in Las Vegas Nevada Leonidas
hesitates for a bit but ultimately
declines the offer much to Xerxes dismay
as a result the two sets of soldiers
have a Yo Mama battle which is won by
the Spartans but unfortunately during
their fight dilius gets hit in the face
and his eyes are gouged out by one of
the Persians this is all right following
this the movie cuts to Xerxes Palace
where the deformed Paris Hilton is seen
searching for the king it's revealed
that she is there to betray the Spartans
and so she informs Xerxes of the secret
goat path above the hot gates in return
she requests for an expensive Chanel
handbag and for her deformed hump to be
removed from her back the king
immediately obliges and gives her the
handbag however when Xerxes attempts to
remove the deformed hump he is sent
flying by the large amount of mucus
present inside this movie Saw books the
next day while Leonidas eats ice cream
sonio learns that the Persians have
found out about the secret passage and
frantically informs him Leonidas then
approaches his fellow Warrior dillios
who has been rendered blind from the
previous attack he orders delius to
travel back to Sparta so that he can
tell the tales of how the Spartans had
valiantly fought in the War and also to
give his necklace back to Margot
afterwards the King Xerxes and his
Persian army arrive at thermopyle and
ask Leonidas to surrender for the last
time but when he refuses Xerxes gets
frustrated and calls an additional Army
of a million Persians meanwhile Margot
finally faces the loyal counselors and
dances before them giving them a short
show the old men throw bills at her and
cheer her on when suddenly she gets
serious and implores them to send
additional troops to Thermopylae however
traitoro betrays Margot and says that
the Spartans should instead surrender to
Xerxes Margot is furious and unleashes a
venomous rage transforming her into
Spider-Man while tretoro wields powers
of Sandman the two fight and Margot
ultimately defeats tretoro by sucking
him up with the help of a vacuum cleaner
after his defeat the counselors finally
learned from his phone that he was in
fact a traitor to the Spartans as a
result they decide to send additional
troops to adelianitis in battle back in
Thermopylae the war begins between the
two armies in the midst of the fight the
Persians reveal that they have the Ghost
Rider as their secret weapon but he is
easily defeated by Sonia who puts him
out with a fire extinguisher they also
reveal the famous boxer Rocky who
decapitates Sonia in one blow the
captain is enraged and to avenge his son
he kills Rocky by injecting a dangerous
amount of Botox into his head he then
starts celebrating the win by lifting
Rocky's boxing championship belt but
right then Xerxes eliminates him with a
spear through the heart witnessing this
a furious Leonidas begins chasing Xerxes
the scene resembles a Grand Theft Auto
San Andreas style Chase as he hijacks a
person's car and starts dancing after a
while Leonidas gets out of the car and
finds a crow bar which he uses to beat a
Persian guy to death out of nowhere he
then picks up two assault rifles and
opens fire on some enemy troops Xerxes
runs for his life but suddenly trips not
being able to handle his own weight the
Persian king then discovers a
Transformer Cube beside him in the sand
and picks it up all of a sudden he
transforms into a gigantic human robot
and names himself Xerxes Tron the
Spartans cower in fear while Xerxes Tron
shows off his powers by playing a
particular YouTube video on his chest
screen after this he proceeds to attack
the Spartans hoping to win the war once
and for all but when he steps forward he
accidentally trips on his extension cord
and falls to the ground Xerxes dies a
painful death but he also crushes all
the surviving Spartans including
Leonidas meanwhile delios finally
reaches Sparta and hands over the
necklace to Queen Margot the latter is
devastated to learn that her husband is
perished in the War the movie Cuts one
year into the future where a blind
delius leads a larger Spartan Force to
defeat the Persians but because of his
blindness he loses his sense of
direction and ends up leading his army
in a completely different location in
the movie's final moments the Spartans
eventually end up in Malibu California
where they knock down the famous
celebrity Lindsay Lohan as she leaves a
rehabilitation center
[Laughter]
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching